today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video if you
want to see a tragic preview really of
the voter suppression and catastrophic
disenfranchisement that we're going to
see in the November election look no
further than yesterday in Georgia
Georgia among some other states had
primary elections yesterday and you may
or may not even have heard that
elections were going on in local
elections depending on what media
sources you consume you may not even
have been aware that there were problems
or that there were even elections
yesterday but there were and this is
really it's really a crisis level
situation where the United States looks
much more like the developing countries
that are right-wing leaders often
criticize based on what our elections
looked like yesterday we had people
waiting in lines hours and hours long
outdoors in the heat often wearing masks
because we are still by the way dealing
with the corona virus pandemic of course
this was there were shortages of ballots
and this was all disproportionately in
the minority precincts parts of the
state of Georgia where the population is
majority minority places that tend on
average to vote more for Democrats than
they tend to vote for Republicans and at
some point I mean how many times are we
going to see the exact same story and
the answer is probably many sadly but
we've been watching this for election
cycle after election cycle this happened
back in Georgia back in 2018 in Georgia
that was when secretin Secretary of
State Brian Kemp a Republican was
running for governor and as Secretary of
State he oversaw his own election
against Stacey Abrams to be governor of
Georgia ultimately one big surprise and
widespread allegations of the exact same
type of voter suppression
disenfranchisement reduction of polling
places in disproportionately minority
and democratic-leaning areas it's the
same game and the
reason that Republicans are going to
aggressively push this in Georgia is
that Georgia is increasingly a contested
state now I don't want to you know
pretend like it's a battleground state
in any real sense right now
presidentially for now it's still a
state that trump is likely going to win
modestly easily he's up in the polls
about seven points right now in Georgia
he'll almost certainly win but the point
is Georgia in local and state elections
is increasingly purple it's close enough
for Trump that he's going to have to
spend some money there which is money he
can't spend in two places he's going to
spend it there instead of somewhere else
back in 2016 Donald Trump only one
Georgia by five percentage points in the
2012 election Mitt Romney had defeated
Barack Obama by eight in Georgia and
again it's the state and local races are
maybe suggestive of what we might see in
the future in Georgia which is more of a
centrist lean than a hard right lean and
Republicans are understandably very
worried so we we saw a preview yesterday
in Georgia of what we're going to see in
a ton of places in the fall this
includes Florida Ohio Wisconsin really
it's like every contested battleground
state that was important to Trump in
2016 that he can't really afford to lose
without putting his reelection at risk
we are going to see this exact same
thing now of course lots of Georgia
voters you'll be glad to know had no
problem at all voting yesterday its
voters who disproportionately vote in
overwhelmingly white precincts and they
were widely reporting listen I showed up
and voted in five minutes there was no
line what are people complaining about
and that's exactly the strategy make it
really easy for voters that are
statistically more likely to vote
Republican to vote make it much more
difficult for voters that at the
aggregate you know broad mathematical
level are more likely to vote for
Democrats and it's the same betrayal of
Georgia voters once again this is
election rigging we have to stop using
these softer terms like there were
reports of isolated irregular
charities come on there were delays
voting in some precincts those are
essentially gaslighting terms this is
rigging because it's intentional it's
calculated it's an effort to swing
results by controlling and manipulating
and sort of molding who gets to vote
easily versus who's going to have
trouble voting so a few things have to
happen first we need as many nonprofit
groups as possible to be armed and ready
to fight every voter suppression attempt
when they try to reduce polling places
cut early voting hours put stricter
guidelines for requesting an absentee
ballot purge voter rolls as we've seen
done in a number of different states
we need these nonprofit groups suing
every single time and gumming up any of
these attempts as much as possible
that's number one number two anybody who
can either vote early or vote absentee
should plan to vote early and/or vote
absentee and should understand what the
process looks like now in some places
you will have access to both an absentee
ballot vote by mail oh and early voting
you will have your choice of the two in
some places it's one or the other
depending on the absentee ballot rules
or the early voting rules so inform
yourself about what is going on where
you vote the absentee ballot you request
from the state ahead of time some states
are saying because of coronavirus
they'll send everybody an application
for an absentee ballot others are
looking at sending of the ballots
themselves but the point is the normal
processes you request a ballot you get
it you fill it out you mail it in that's
it you're done okay
early voting is in-person voting
depending on the state sometimes about
three weeks before the election day in
this case November 3rd early voting will
start it's usually limited locations
like here in Boston if I want to vote
early I can't vote in my neighborhood I
have to go to one of I think it's like
five or six locations including City
Hall all the way downtown find out where
that is as many people as possible
should take advantage of whichever
method is available in their state and
whatever is easier for you now one last
thing
the Georgia Secretary of State says
there's going to be an investigation
into what happened yesterday now I
really want you to understand how absurd
this is Brian Kemp was Secretary of
State in November of 2018 and he ran the
election in which he was a candidate for
governor and lo and behold he won amidst
allegations of voter suppression
now another Secretary of State is going
to investigate voter suppression that he
presided over to help his own party it's
a joke we are a joke it's I got a bunch
of emails yesterday and today from
European viewers saying what's going on
in the US with your voting system like
how is this still a problem in one of
the richest countries in the world and
the answer is it's a problem by design
we could solve this but there isn't a
problem if you ask the people that
benefit from this voter suppression
there are now calls this is unbelievable
there are calls for the u.s. to bring in
United Nations elections observers in
November to try to ensure that there are
fair elections in the United States this
is how unreliable and pathetic our
election system is and we're gonna see a
lot more of it as we get a closer and
closer to November in a stunning new
poll Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell is losing to challenger
Ami McGrath in his Kentucky Senate
re-election race now I'll give you the
caveats in a moment but the fact that
this is even close is already a really
big deal it's typically not close at all
in Kentucky for Mitch McConnell in his
re-elections there's a new poll from RMG
group and it has Amy McGrath up 41 240mm
agree as you may know is an Air Force
veteran and challenging one of the one
of the longest sitting senators and the
longest ever tenured senator out of
Kentucky now what's very very
interesting is that the poll is 41 40 in
favor of Amy McGrath it's within the
margin of error a statistical tie
certainly when people participating in
the poll are told Amy McGrath favors
congressional term limits and Mitch
McConnell opposes them which is true
her support actually increases pretty
dramatically but there are a lot of
undecided still in this poll and there
are certainly a fair number of people
supporting someone other than Mitch
McConnell or Amy McGrath so when we
typically talk about the Senate in 2020
and we think about what's the most
likely path that Democrats could have to
take in control of the Senate in 2020 we
often go to Arizona where Mark Kelly is
very much ahead of martha mcsalley the
incumbent Republican will look at Cory
Gardner Republican incumbent in Colorado
who is well behind and may lose we think
about Susan Collins and Maine Tom Tillis
in North Carolina maybe Steve Bullock in
Montana there's a few others I'm not
talking about all of them but we don't
usually talk about Mitch McConnell Mitch
McConnell has been one of the most
effective Republican legislators in
years he's gotten a ton of right-wing
judges confirmed he's successfully
blocked Barack Obama's Supreme Court
pick Merrick garland holding that seat
open for a year until Donald Trump was
inaugurated and ultimately selected Neil
Gorsuch that is horrifying horrifying
but if you are a Republican that's a
major accomplishment and that should
have been Barack Obama's selection and
Mitch McConnell was able to hold it for
Donald Trump disgusting but if you're on
their side you love it it would be
incredible to remove Mitch McConnell and
he's currently down one now let me give
you the caveat Mitch McConnell is down
one but it's 41 to 40 so statistically
it's a tie and the Challenger at some
point is going to need to get to 50% or
close to it
Amy McGrath is at 41 if she can't start
getting to 45 48 closer to 50 typically
in these elections the undecideds and
the third-party holdouts as we get
closer to Election Day are going to
break for the incumbent in this case
it's Mitch McConnell so Amy McGrath
ceiling could be the 41 that she has
right now which is not going to be
enough to win it but it's a fight it's a
fight anti McConnell Kentuckians should
get involved in this race it would be a
race if you're in a state that doesn't
have a hotly contested Senate seat you
could get involved in phone banking
and fundraising for Amy McGrath
McConnell has been in the US Senate
longer than any other senator from
Kentucky has ever been Mitch McConnell
went to the Senate in 1985 the year
after I was born Mitch McConnell went to
the Senate and Mitch McConnell is still
in the Senate it's too much it's too
much he's gotta go he's been a Senate
Majority Leader for five years since
2015 and he has left a massive
destruction in his wake and if indeed
Mitch McConnell loses it would be a huge
bellwether for how the entire Senate is
going now usually when we do analyses we
say here's how this one race is going
here's how this other race is going the
reality is that these things come in
waves if the incumbent from 1985
Republican majority leader is knocked
out in Kentucky a lot of these other
races are likely to go in the direction
of Democrats and we will probably if
that happens have Donald Trump to thank
seats and states that are rarely if ever
in play for Democrats are now a fight
even forcing Republicans to have to
spend money to defend them is a victory
because these are often very easy to win
states and races for Republicans so pick
a race if it's in your state great if
you're in a state without a close
election find something nearby or
something you're interested in there is
plenty to be done and this being
Kentucky I'm thinking about getting a
nice bottle of Kentucky bourbon to have
for election night coverage and if Mitch
McConnell loses on November 3rd maybe
we'll open that up even though it will
be a very big uphill battle but by the
way the the warning is because this
polling is closed this piggybacks on the
earlier story about the suppression we
saw yesterday in Georgia because this
election is closed we should expect that
Kentucky Republicans are going to go
extra hard on the voter suppression and
the other types of election fraud
tactics so we will likely need extra
margin if Amy McGrath is to defeat Mitch
McConnell it's been happening this week
in Georgia and elsewhere massive poll
closures creating very large waits and
disproportionately Democratic areas we
know the tactics but we've got to fight
them okay next week Tuesday night 8 p.m.
Eastern we will be having the second
David Pakman show chess tournament this
is free to all this is not Members Only
there's no fee this
is just free it's just building
sportsmanship and camaraderie in a
difficult time so that'll be Tuesday
June 16th at 8:00 p.m. Eastern the
tournament will be on Leach s org I'll
have more info about that but put it in
your calendar I hope you'll play we had
500 players last time and I hope we do
better than that
in the meantime make sure to let me know
what you think about this McConnell race
on Twitter I am deep hackman on twitter
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Shawna Webb Becky and David
hooray
thanks to Sean and David for your
support really appreciated as well as
the folks that have signed up and just
stuck around for a while and one of
those people is James Atkins who is
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day
grab a membership get the commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show
every day a sign up at join pakman.com
if you would like a discount not a
little discount a big discount you can
use the coupon code 20/20 now that saves
you 66 percent just a massive massive
discount which is optional optional and
everybody regardless of coupon codes
will get a thank you from me at some
point at some point okay let's get to
hate reott mail if you don't remember
what hatred mail is it has been a couple
weeks since we had our last one here's a
quick reminder we are getting to the
oranges of this investigation so god
bless do united states america patriot
man written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom all right here is this week's
hatred mail as usual needing no
introduction
have you ever don't discuss politics
very wise advice from mr. David Park man
don't stir the pot with your canned
spirits I'm David Parkman
I worry so much about what people think
about me that I suffocate myself with a
mask I'm a beta snowflake sheep it's a
shame when your show has become mates
yeah I mean I'm not I'm having trouble
parsing the grammar a little bit there
but this is a political show so we do
discuss politics I'm have you ever don't
discuss politics may be interpreted most
charitably means do we talk about other
things on the show and certainly we do
but it is primarily a political program
by the way you know that speaking of
discussing politics
in the last couple of months it seems
that because of coronavirus now with the
protests with what is essentially a
referendum on Donald Trump coming up in
November more and more people have been
writing to me saying I feel compelled to
talk about politics with my family even
though I don't usually coworkers even
even though I don't usually my
significant others parents even though I
don't usually do you think that there
should be this taboo around talking
about politics and religion where in
many other countries that is it is much
more normal to do that and I'm going to
address that in detail on the Friday
show anybody who knows how I grew up
which is politics is a central piece of
what is discussed at family gatherings
at the dinner table etc I believe that
we need to distinct from talking about
politics especially because if we don't
talk about you know I'm kind of going
off on a tangent from the voicemail
caller but from the hatred mail of here
but if we don't talk about politics and
model that people can have disagreements
and then everything is still okay and
then you just finish your dinner and
then you play a video game or watch a TV
show and everybody can still get along
if we don't model that by taking off the
stigma of discussion of politics and
religion then the model people will have
is the way politics is discussed on
social media which is toxic trash so I
am very much in favor of making
political and religious discussions just
mainstream among work co-workers family
etc in the meantime if you want to fight
hate racism you can use the coupon code
hey tree at 14 to save 40% off of your
membership of choice at join pakman.com
one of the stories that stands out in
terms of police brutality from the last
week or ten days of protests is the
video of 75 year old martin Gugino being
shoved on to the ground by two Buffalo
Police officers Buffalo New York hitting
his head so hard that he actually
started bleeding from his right ear
seemingly knocked unconscious when it
happened the two officers involved in
that incident have been charged with
second-degree assault after they were
filmed
knocking Gugino over these two officers
are 39 year old Aaron tur Golf ski and
32 year old Robert McCabe they've both
pleaded not guilty and they've both been
suspended without pay and this incident
led to the resignations of dozens of
Buffalo police officers no no not
because they are protesting what these
two officers did because they are
defending what the two officers did in
shoving Martin Guji Guji no and now
Donald Trump is actually attacking wait
for it the 75 year old guy who was put
into critical condition by the officers
The Daily Beast reports that as of
Monday afternoon Gugino had been
upgraded from critical to serious but
stable and Donald Trump yesterday spread
a completely baseless conspiracy theory
that Gugino was some part of an Tifa
setup of the police officers a planned
provocation of some kind this is
something that's been alleged by Donald
Trump's latest favorite propaganda
outlet Oh a n Donald from tweeting
yesterday quote Buffalo protesters
shoved by police could be an anti fapri
vaca tour 75 year old Martin Gugino was
pushed away after appearing to scan
police communications in order to black
out their equipment Oh a n I watched he
fell harder than was pushed was aiming
scanner could be a setup now the a lot
of the debate is over whether this could
be true rather than the insanity of
Donald Trump the president even tweeting
something like this but just to do our
thorough due diligence here's the story
Trump is referring to from Oh a and take
a look and you'll be able to tell that
Trump is just completely uncritically
falling for obvious adjectives and ax
take a look new reports find a protester
pushed by Buffalo police was appearing
to use comment and Tifa tactics
when America's Christian Rose looks into
the matter any report finds the latest
tensions of the Buffalo Police
Department's could be a result of a
false flag provocation by far left group
and so far so I'm cutting the video
there because we'll be demonetised if we
show the actual footage of googy know
being knocked down but you get the idea
of the story on Oh a n so I need you to
understand that this is a completely
baseless conspiracy it was even
suggested that you you know again came
equipped with some kind of fake blood
dispenser and that what appears to be
Gugino bleeding from his ear is actually
not imagine how absurd this is he was an
auntie philantropy sin2 pushing him so
he could slam his own head into the
pavement and put himself in the hospital
for a week what a big win for the
protesters right now in contrast Donald
Trump is attacking an elderly man who
was assaulted by police and yet he has
said nothing about the KKK member who
drove into a crowd of protesters a few
days ago now you might hear me say that
and you might be wondering KKK what are
you talking about David I didn't hear
about that
and that's exactly part of the problem
you might not even have heard of this
story but in Hanover Virginia 36 year
old Harry Rogers was arrested after he
drove his truck into a crowd of
protesters and it has now been admitted
that he is a known leader of the Ku Klux
Klan and a disseminator of what is
considered or called a confederate
ideology Trump has said nothing about
that but is defending police in one of
the most brutal anecdotes of these
protesters while suggesting that the
victim a 75 year old peace activist
might be an auntie FAP Lant equipped
with surreptitious police monitoring
technology so what I would like to see
Republicans come out and say is not
whether they believe Trump's conspiracy
theory the oen conspiracy theory I would
like them to come out and say that
merely getting involved in this type of
thing is an absolute atrocity for a
president to do because a lot of the
debate sadly is about whether
Martin Gugino might be a provocateur
whether Martin Gugino might have brought
a fake blood device of some kind the
real issue is that the president is even
involved in this absolute gutter trash
and the effect of all of this is that it
just continues to divide the country if
Trump can divide the country about such
an obvious clear-cut case of police
brutality by sowing doubt and
uncertainty by amplifying a story from
OAM he is preventing people from coming
together about anything like if people
can't come together about this incident
then the country can be divided about
almost anything and we have to remind
ourselves that this is the president of
the United States who is saying these
things and participating in this stuff
this is what we would normally expect to
see people like Alex Jones tweeting
about and it's the president who's
tweeting about it
how does he have millions tens of
millions of supporters still and at a
certain point you know I I did the
segment a couple maybe a year little
more ago called we have to accept that
there's a lot of stupid people and the
segment clearly resonated and did very
very well although some people took
offense to it we have to understand that
this says something really horrifying
about our country that Donald Trump can
be saying these things and doing these
things and maintaining the support of
tens of millions of people
despite tweeting such obvious adjectives
we're gonna continue following this on
the David Pakman show Instagram page
which is david pakman show on instagram
also follow me on instagram at david
pakman I think tomorrow or the next day
we're gonna have a video of me
harvesting my one strawberry from my
garden and a single leaf of mint and
eating it preparing it in a gourmet
fashion that's on my personal Instagram
David Pakman follow the show on
Instagram for more on this story at
David Pakman
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on your support and the easiest way is
through membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show it's great to
welcome to the program today Adrienne
Barney who's professor of philosophy at
Wake Forest University and also author
of the book the truth about denial bias
and self-deception in science politics
and religion it's really great to have
you on I appreciate it
hey David thanks for having me so to
start with denialism how far back does
denialism go as far as we know I mean
we're there early denialists when there
were the you know original theories
about what are humans and what is outer
space and is whether God or simply the
machinations of climate or I mean like
how far back does denialism go in some
way shape or form well well yes all of
the all of the above I would I would
send it back several million years as a
matter of fact so so Homo sapiens
evolved in small groups and going back
further to our ancestors they were in
the same situation and the the it's a
really important adaptive trait if
you're living in a small group to be
able to integrate yourself into the
group's ideological worldview you know
if your group worships Poseidon you
better figure out a way to believe in
Poseidon otherwise you're out for
example right so it's really deep deep
in our evolutionary history that we have
formed this talent for rationalizing
beliefs in our
in order to integrate with a with a
larger worldview so yes and so then that
moves forward through history all kinds
of religious beliefs obviously that's
probably the the beginning of it all
beliefs about other groups because what
our evolutionary context to us we
evolved in small groups that were in
competition with other groups so if we
hate the group if you know if our group
hates the group we'll get across the
river I'm gonna find reasons to hate
that group too otherwise I'm not able to
integrate myself into my own group
because we don't we don't survive well
on our own cooperation social
cooperation that's our evolutionary
niche that's that's that's what gives us
our advantage so early on there was an
evolutionarily advantageous reason why
we were able to sort of potentially
suppress contradictory information in
order to be in line with with our group
does that still hold true today in the
same way I mean is it an issue of
evolutionary advantage at this point
well it's well a lot of things that in
the past were an advantage aren't
necessarily an avenge now but it's still
there it's all deep so deep in our
cognitive makeup that we have we have
these skills we're actually very very
good at adapting our beliefs not just
our behavior but our beliefs to our
situation and you mentioned you know
ignoring evidence or you know picking
out the evidence that you want
rationalizing and what's called
confirmation bias right you ignore the
evidence you don't want and these you
seek out you know evidence or reasons to
believe what you want to believe anyway
and that becomes actually particularly
toxic in our current media environment
where you can go wherever you want to to
get the worldview that that you want to
believe and you get the picture of the
world presented to you in in you know HD
video and described to you the way you
want to hear it and it you know it and
so we have but you know what's called
these no media bubbles that people get
into in addition to things like our
geographic sorting here in the United
States in particular peoples have a sort
of
themselves very well geographically into
like-minded communities is there any
demographic trends that you see in terms
of denialism and and sort of rejection
of Diskin form of confirmatory evidence
maybe like in terms of age is there a
certain age at which this becomes more
prevalent and if so is is that an
education or a cultural thing or
anything demographically that you've
observed well you'll you'll hear
different theories from different social
scientists about this younger people
have demonstrated a little more
cognitive flexibility and openness older
folks are as you would say you know or
more set in their ways they're also a
little more sensitive to threat we feel
more threatened and that's a really big
factor here if we also look at the
progressive slash liberal versus
conservative ways of thinking about the
world so where conservatives and
conservatives obviously skew at this
point in the u.s. wider and older
obviously conservatives by definition
are what we call system justify errs
they are pro status quo conservatives
are comfortable with the way things are
in terms of the social and economic
order and its hierarchies and they will
they will seek out reasons to dismiss
evidence that there's something wrong
with that order such as you know
systemic inequality and and younger
people are less prone to do that so it
seems like there's an asymmetry there in
the sense that when you talk about the
status quo and you think about inertia
certainly it takes less energy to
maintain the status quo in general all
else being equal then it would to change
the status quo and so there is a sort of
it seems that there would be a
structural advantage to those who are
predisposed to keep things the same
because it's easier to do so in a sense
well the status quo is upheld by all
kinds of systems for example the police
the police are the in any society the
police are the tip of the spear when it
comes to maintaining the social and
economic hierarchy that's what they're
that's when we say law and order that's
what the order part of that means you
know when Trump calls himself steel or
Nixon calls himself the law and order
president don't call myself the law and
order president that's what the order is
the order is maintaining the current
social and economic hierarchy and that
includes obviously systems of systemic
racial bias and and systemic in a
structural economic inequality I'm
interested in climate change in this
context because we could think about a
way in which denying climate change goes
against the known facts and may be
advantageous if you're part of certain
political groups right so in order to
keep the peace as you suggest we may
have this tendency to say hey let's I
mean even if there's information that
suggests climate change is real and it's
man-made I'm gonna stick with my group
but over the long term if it's true what
science says about the climate
it's self-destructive to the human race
and to the planet so it seems that there
there is a long term disadvantage when
it comes to the sort of evolutionary
aspect of it how could how should we
interpret climate change denial in this
context David I'm very interested in
climate change denial as I'm glad you
bring it up
the first thing I'd want to stress is
that being a climate science denial list
has nothing to do with being stupid or
being uneducated in fact what we see is
the reverse if you're if you're a
conservative you're more likely to be a
climate science denier if you have
college education you're more likely
when you to give people a test not just
on science literacy but climate science
literacy you're more likely to be a
denier if you're conservative that when
you score higher on
climate science literacy test so what is
that telling us that telling us is that
we are really good at rationalizing our
own beliefs the more information we have
the more ammunition we get to
rationalize those beliefs this puts us
in a classic a game theoretical
situation I don't know if I want to get
too technical on this but yeah where
individual decisions about what's best
for them in terms of what belief systems
they want to hold on to become
collectively absolutely disastrous in
the long run so that's interesting so in
other words the the more information we
have maybe not the more that our beliefs
align with what we would call an
empirical reality but the better we are
at justifying the beliefs that we have
well we have more capacity to
rationalize it doesn't we doesn't mean
we have to but there is a definitely a
tendency to do so I mean we love to
think of ourselves as these purely
rational beings and all our beliefs are
based on evidence and listening to
qualified experts but in practice that's
not what happens when there when it's
beliefs when that when we're presented
with facts that are threatening to us so
our our very sense of identity is based
on the groups that we you know feel
associated with our like if I said if I
said you David David tell me about
yourself right now well I'm gonna - I'm
gonna make up some things about you so I
say hey hey David tell me about yourself
- who are you and you'd say well like
well you know I was I was born in Rhode
Island but I grew up in Texas my parents
immigrated from Ireland I'm a Methodist
I'm a social conservative but I feel
strongly about the environment and all
of those facts that when you be telling
me all about yourself all of those
things are our relations you have two
other groups and in in terms of their
ideological worldview that's your
identity so when you're presented with
facts that challenge the the worldviews
of the groups that you associated with
it feels like a personal attack you have
an emotional response and our brains are
totally set up to defend themselves
and we defend ourselves by through
rational lace rationalization
confirmation bias what we call motivated
reasoning you have a conclusion in mind
there's no such thing as climate change
and then you seek out reasons to believe
that and you discount the reasons you're
given to believe that there is climate
change right and once again in our media
environment you can always find what
you're looking for when you're looking
for reasons to rationalize your own
belief system so that gets me to sort of
the last major thing I want to touch on
which is we've now widely read and
researched and and discovered that just
giving people more facts and data is not
very effective at changing minds in fact
they can do the opposite as you say
people can see that as a threat and and
further kind of plant their feet and
wear where they are what are the more
effective ways to get people to
reconsider their beliefs and to throw
out just a couple of things the one
debate that I've had with some people
and Nathan J Robinson when when I spoke
to him he felt very strongly that
appealing to people on the basis of
their values and tying that to the
conclusion you want is not a good idea
so for example like appealing to fiscal
conservatives to end the death penalty
on the cost issue when in reality that
may not be the primary reason I might
want to end the death penalty there's
debate over whether that's a good idea
or a bad idea
ballpark for us the best strategies for
effectively getting people to change
their beliefs III agree with that
there's a lot of talk about message
framing basically marketing your message
to your audience frame it and their
values in terms of their values hey
you're a conservative let's talk about
conserving the environment right you're
an evangelical let's talk about caring
for God's creation
maybe over the very long term with a lot
of interactions and if you put that all
in the right context for a long period
of time that could change people's minds
a few interactions along those lines
it's like it's like what was that old
king who took his sword and tried to
stop the the waves come from coming in
right right it people have this lifetime
of cultural identifications and I end
identity
that that are just gonna blow that that
kind of intervention out of the water I
would I would say rather appeal to local
issues that are local interests right
talk about okay I was just reading about
Miami and the fact that Miami is their
saltwater intrusion into the freshwater
supply now everyone in everyone in
Southeast Florida no matter what
political persuasion you are really
cares about having drinking water and
not having flooding right so don't talk
about climate change don't talk about
the evidence for climate change just say
okay we've got a sea water problem in
our freshwater supply what do we do
about that I would start there you know
talk about you know in the in the in the
American West talk of El drought in an
agricultural community right I would
start there that's I'm afraid that's
that's not that doesn't take you all the
way to the kind of global systemic
change that we really need but that's
the beginning there's things you could
do in K through 12 education with the
garage science education that I think
would be much better instead of teaching
people science facts we should we should
be teaching kids scientific method
really focusing on that about curiosity
about debunking claims that are not well
founded and and educate educate kids now
but that's a generational thing but the
thing about climate change is that we
don't really have time for that so it's
an urgent crisis and and I I don't have
this sort of Magic Bullet in terms of a
message or words send out this message
yeah and we're gonna convert everybody
including those people who are invested
in the status quo so heavily that
they're gonna discount that evidence
automatically it's tough but certainly I
agree that at a systemic level starting
with media literacy and critical
thinking far earlier as well we are we
are kind of it's a long game but we are
sort of better better setting up society
to think think in that way the book is
the truth about denial bias and
self-deception in science politics and
religion we've been speaking with the
book
author Adrian Barton who's professor of
philosophy at Wake Forest University
really appreciate your time today thanks
so much David the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
Donald Trump's press secretary Kaley
mcenany was asked at her Monday press
briefing by reporters whether Donald
Trump plans to resume the coronavirus
press briefings and she didn't answer
the question but the answer is obviously
no and it's a good question to ask
because we're seeing massive coronavirus
hot spots growing very rapidly in the
United States mostly different areas
than the early hot spots and I'm going
to talk about the virus itself shortly
but there's a real media story here to
understand we talked about the bully
pulpit of corporate media much of what
is in the national discussion the top
three stories that are in the national
discussion at any given time are
essentially led by corporate media and
this is called agenda setting power it's
not necessarily that corporate media
tells us what to think about any
particular issue although sometimes they
do but it's that corporate media tells
us what to think about what to talk
about and I'll give you an example
remember kids in cages the immigration
scandal it's still going on but it's
rarely if ever in the media except to
mentioned that some people being held at
the border have contracted coronavirus
but nothing has fundamentally changed
about that story which was wall-to-wall
coverage previously during this
administration now it's like it doesn't
exist then it was coronavirus we have a
pandemic daily press briefings including
Donald Trump and doctors pouchy and
Burks daily updates down to the specific
details about the number of masks and
project air bridge flights from Mike
Pence and then the White House signaled
we're going to stop Trump wondered aloud
about injecting bleach and isopropyl
alcohol to treat coronavirus it became
clear that the White House didn't really
want more visibility for doctors Burks
and Foudy talking about the virus so the
briefing stopped and with that over time
as more and more states have decided to
reopen some are safely reopening some
are very unsafely reopening the topic of
the virus itself started to take a
backseat especially as the George Floyd
killing took place and the massive
protest started and now as we're seeing
the protests
are starting to die down a little bit
but the big topic has become defund the
police or do not defund the police
depending on whose perspective you're
listening to right-wing media saying
defunding the police would be anarchy
some on the Left furious that Biden does
not want to defund the police but
understand that nothing materially has
changed with coronavirus we'll look at
the data put it up on the screen now
fortunately as you can see we've seen a
leveling off and a slow decline in the
number of cases at the national level
but mostly what we're seeing is the
cases being relocated where we are
finding new hot spots understand that at
the peak we were finding 25 to 30,000
cases a day we are still finding 19 to
25 thousand new cases every single day
and the number of active cases meaning
people who currently have the virus is
still as high as it's ever been and yet
Donald Trump barely talks about
coronavirus his press secretary barely
talks about coronavirus right-wing media
is done with it other than calling it a
scam or a conspiracy and even corporate
media is increasingly talking about
coronavirus less and less but we have a
new political article that points out
not only is the pandemic still very much
a pandemic with no effective treatment
no vaccine we have new hot spots that
are setting records for new cases there
are parts of the country that are
exploding with virus cases and Donald
Trump is just silent another massive
failure because Trump by not talking
about it makes people think the threat
is over
meaning they go out and behavior
responsibly and cause even more cases
and in fact as we talked about yesterday
on the bonus show Donald Trump is
planning to restart his huge mag or
Ally's as part of his 2020 re-election
campaign in a couple of weeks so I'll
give you some really specific examples
Texas which started to reopen pretty
quickly is exploding week to week they
have more and more cases the number of
active cases in Texas is higher today
than it has ever been
Florida run by Republican governor Ron
de Santos
also started to open pretty early they
were caught lying about numbers as we
previously covered and after a small dip
sometime in April which might have just
been them lying they once again in
Florida are seeing record numbers of new
cases now I mentioned that the cases are
dramatically shifting from some parts of
the country to others this doesn't mean
you know Kings aren't going terribly
everywhere I am thrilled to say that
here in Massachusetts at least for now
cases have been very steadily declining
since late April the graph I'm showing
you you'll see a one-day spike about a
week ago that's not really a spike that
that was a bunch of presumptive cases
from the three months of coronavirus
were all added in on that day but we are
looking really good here and I'm
thrilled to see that so this is a story
not just about the virus itself which is
still raging with no treatment or
vaccine but it's a media story as well
about the agenda-setting power that
corporate media has we said six save
seven weeks ago Trump's strategy is
going to be just start pretending it
doesn't exist start talking about the
economy jobs reopening and a bunch of
corporate media has played along now in
the meantime things are so bad here in
the United States with coronavirus that
as more and more countries or reopening
travel the United States is being banned
I'll give you an example Iceland has so
dominated the virus that Iceland decided
that on I believe it's June 15th they're
going to reopen tourism when you get to
Iceland you have to have a kovat test at
the airport or quarantine for 14 days
people are going to be able to go to
Iceland and start doing tourism if
that's what they want to do except
Americans aren't going to be allowed
because things are so out of control
here other countries people are going to
be allowed to start going to Iceland not
Americans because it's a disaster and I
wouldn't be surprised if this continues
as the virus keeps spreading in
different US states other countries are
going to be increasingly controlling it
not Brazil India you know there's places
that are that Russia that aren't
controlling it but more and more
countries are going to be allowed to
restart travel and Americans are going
to be banned from going to other
countries
because it is so poorly handled here now
as far as the framing and the propaganda
expect Trump soon to start arguing that
an Tifa and other left-wing protesters
are responsible for spreading the virus
if the numbers keep growing in a lot of
these new hotspots like Florida and
Texas I would anticipate that Donald
Trump will take the protests as the
perfect opportunity to say it's an Tifa
and lefties that are now responsible if
he even mentions it at all and to be
clear the protests will cause some
number of new cases what we're seeing
now is reflective of the situation 10 to
14 days ago and that's important to
remember be ready for it because it's
going to happen and don't forget we're
still in the middle of a pandemic which
some doctors believe is still in its
beginning phases which is overwhelming
to think about so you have to see this
video to believe it Sean Hannity from
Fox News is promoting a pepper spray and
tear gas gun on his live nightly
television program here in the United
States if you don't know we have a
propaganda news channel called Fox News
and with some rare exceptions Fox News
basically carries water for Republicans
and significantly carries water for
Donald Trump yesterday Sean Hannity
promoted a projectile gun powered by co2
cartridges which shoots balls of pepper
spray and tear gas now this is
considered a chemical weapon that is
banned in international warfare I'll
talk about that a little bit later check
out the video from Sean Hannity's
program etho methods that the police
could do take a look at your screen look
at that I by the way no fan the
financial interest in burner gun but I
purchased a number of them yes full
price I paid now I met with them yeah
and I purchased the number of their
items now again this is a an alternative
it won't kill people non-lethal defense
non-lethal it shoots small projectiles
filled with pepper sprayed tear gas and
by the way unlike these Thun guns which
have an incredibly short range and the
stupid wires this weapons accurate up to
50 feet why because I own one
and even come equipped with lasers so
you can't really miss for accuracy now
we didn't show the video I wanted to
we'll get it up later in the show where
it actually will play for you what
happens when it when somebody gets it
with it they don't die and say it could
hopefully be an alternative in a very
volatile dangerous situation whatever
new technology we can develop now
according to a report
I like how Hannity clarifies that he
doesn't have an investment in the
manufacturer burna which would be the
natural thing we would imagine because
it sounds and looks like an infomercial
happening in the middle of his program
it sort of sounds like the context is
he's trying to propose ways that police
could deal with protesters to avoid
hurting them or maybe for police to deal
with encounters like the George Floyd
encounter so I played this for you for
two different reasons first the visual
of it is crazy
it looks like an infomercial Hannity is
promoting specific weapons on his
program which is a wild thing for news
programs to be doing he's also spreading
misinformation Hannity is promoting this
like it's a paintball gun which by the
way if you get hit in the eye with a
paintball gun it can still do damage but
if you get hit in the eye with a pepper
spray or tear gas ball you could not
only lose the eye there can be very
serious reactions to pepper spray and
tear gas even on the basic facts Sean
Hannity is acting like this is like a
harmless tool when it is not at all
harmless there are international case
reports of tear gas causing death
through eventual respiratory failure and
there's other just horrifying examples
and in the context of coronavirus one of
the things you're not supposed to do is
touch your eyes and you want to try to
avoid coughing and sneezing on other
people when you deploy tear gas and
pepper spray in large crowds people
immediately start rubbing their eyes
coughing sneezing onto the people next
to them so this is a bad idea in general
it's a particularly bad idea now with
corona virus and in studies done on
members of the military were very often
they will be exposed to tear gas as part
of their training it increases your risk
of contracting the flu pneumonia
bronchitis and other respiratory
illnesses so this is
not without consequence as Hannity is
trying to argue next teargas is
considered a chemical weapon and it's
banned in war a dating back to 1993 now
you might say okay it might be banned
internationally but the United States
isn't part of that yes it is the United
States ratified the ban on these tools
weapons in 1997 but domestically tear
gas instead of being considered a banned
chemical weapon is considered an
approved riot control agent and it's
permitted for law enforcement use it is
actually so common in the United States
that people may not realize teargas is
banned in international warfare and we
have American law enforcement using it
for crowd control and compliance during
domestic protests which are protected by
the First Amendment banned on the
battlefield used regularly in American
cities
so that's layer 1 and layer 2 now the
deeper issue here
Hannity like many people on the right
comes at all of these issues with the
attitude of what gun or weapon or
aggressive tactic could we introduce
into a situation that's already volatile
that's how they approach these issues
they never go to how could we
de-escalate a situation to prevent
officers from even needing or believing
that they need tear gas guns to begin
with this is the problem and when when
police bring out tear gas into a chaotic
situation it creates more chaos and the
protests become more chaotic and it
leads to even harsher reactions from
police this is a completely optional
self-reinforcing feedback loop the
de-escalation tactics like you know
transparent communication empathy
negotiation we've seen examples of all
of this stuff that's how you stop the
cycle of escalation
instead Sean Hannity is talking about
here's a tear gas gun you could use and
apparently it's within law enforcement
big picture to understand that the
priority should rather than being better
armed with riot shields and night sticks
be de-escalation tactics and this is a
big part of the police reform that I've
been outlining over the last few days on
the show we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p here
is a pretty straightforward question and
and I have a pretty straightforward
answer from one of our voicemail callers
take a listen uh hello David big show up
see my remains in the one nine area for
them living all northwest ohio rural
communities anyway my question was how
much stupidity and we're just blatant
disregard for the truth can Republicans
take a lot a my opinion that's what
she's gonna come down to how well jumped
in vs the public and I think you could
do that rather well but I just I I don't
I was around with many Republicans I
don't understand how they can believe
everything even brainwashed and I just
it sad look at so so you're there's
actually there's a lot of things that
are different that are going on you have
a contingent of people who support Trump
because they they are cognitively
limited that they're sort of they're
ignorant they're ignorant to what's
going on and they lack critical thinking
skills so they just fall for stuff
that's one component number two there
are people on the right who are going to
vote for Trump's reelection merely to
own the libs as they like to say they
refuse to consider voting for a Democrat
despite the fact that Hillary Clinton
and Joe Biden have been very centrist
Democrats in in a lot of ways and on
principle in order to you know attack or
win against liberals they just are going
to vote for Donald Trump's reelection
that's another contingent you've got a
third contingent that is people that
recognize the dishonesty and the lies
but they see recognizing this by voting
for someone else as kind of like
admitting that they failed that they got
tricked in 2016 so there's like a
cognitive dissonance that's going on
where a lot of voters can't abandon
Trump because of what it would say about
them right and and so that's another
component and then there is another
contingent that actually benefits from
Trump's policy they're able to you know
run businesses extra profitably as the
regulatory apparatus of the United
States looks away under Trump or
whatever right they have some personal
stake and they say the hell to hell with
everybody else so there's not one answer
and there is stupidity there is
tolerance of lies but there's a lot more
to it than just that but a very very
good question and well said I hope that
you will join the second David Pakman
show chess tournament it's going to be
Tuesday June 18th at 8 p.m. Eastern Time
it's open to everybody all skill levels
it'll be on LY chess org that's li chess
org you can register now and then I'll
be streaming my participation in the
chess tournament we had 500 players in
the first one I hope we do better than
that this time around we also have a
great bonus show coming up for you today
we will talk about the burning of a
police precinct and the degree of
approval among the American public for
it I'll preview for you that it's quite
low number two the program cops has been
cancelled in the wake of what is going
on with George Floyd and number three
the dictionary merriam-webster will be
updating its definition of racism in
light of what is going on all of these
stories and more on today's bonus show
two ways to access it become a member at
join pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I'll
see you then
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue chicom and use the promo code david
i've put a link right underneath this
video